Blasphemous 2 trailer finally so for
those of you who don't know there's a
game out there it's a metroidvania
called Blasphemous and I'm kind of in
love with it for the sake of setup for
this video about three years ago I
played Blasphemous and I was like I'm
gonna do a video on Blasphemous I
reviewed Blasphemous I thought it was
fantastic I did not at the time know how
head over heels in love I would fall for
this game all this is to say 100 of the
game maxed out the game got the Platinum
done all the penances though as we know
the Penance never ends done all the DLC
I listened to the digital soundtrack
just about every time I'm driving in my
car got the art book got the soundtrack
on vinyl for those moments I'm not in my
car because Carlos Viola his musical
score
huh
fantastic is well he's not a big enough
word looking forward to hearing what he
does in the score for Blasphemous too
also I've played through Blasphemous no
fewer than 10 times at least I say all
of this so you firmly grasp when I saw a
Blasphemous 2 trailer in my feed today
it felt something like that best I can
describe it and although the trailer is
only a minute long it's a quick look we
get to glean certain details for nothing
else we see footage of Blasphemous too
for my fellow penitent ones out there
that's enough we see some new enemies in
here we see other enemies that look like
newer versions of enemies we saw in
Blasphemous one in the end it's still a
dude trying to beat your ass to death
with a Candlestick some new abilities
for combat also puzzle mechanics also
all the [__] up visuals and imagery
we've come to expect and love from
Blasphemous also when you damage enemies
you see the quantifiable damage counter
on screen when you're dealing damage to
enemies makes sense in dealing with what
Blasphemous too shows us to be dealing
with which is not one weapon that you
just upgrade and it's okay to know hey
it's a little stronger go forth and
prosper it's all the information I need
but rather the trailer in this game
shows you're dealing with different
weapons and I imagine these weapons are
going to deal with different enemy types
very differently good to know the
quantifiable amount of damage each
weapon deals to each enemy in that
respect however just for the sake of the
game being a little more crushing kind
of be cool if they have a toggle on off
option so you if you don't want to see
the damage you have that option point is
I make this video not because I feel I
have to but because I truly [__]
wanted to pop A's they love it too my
dogs love it too yes you tell them just
a visual aesthetic of the world is so
imaginative dark [__] up yet beautiful
I don't know it just speaks and again
the musical score Carlos Viola there's
not a track in that soundtrack and that
musical score that I don't love some
more than others sure but it truly is a
soundtrack I'll just put on and never
skip a song that's rare for me per the
trailer Blasphemous 2 is coming out this
summer summer 2023 which is fantastic I
was starting to think it wasn't going to
come out this year and it was going to
be pushed I started to get sad just
listening to Rems Losing My Religion on
repeat but I guess not here we are
anyhow Blasphemous 2 trailer it's out
not all of you will care I totally get
it but those of you who do care
we [__] care
this is the answer to prayers my friends
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]